So we had published a while ago the group that can increase the risk of de novo AML.
And if you look at the pre-malignant patterns for de novo AML, you see a very varied pattern.
TP53 is there, but a lot of it are the de novo mutations, TET2, DNMG3A, RONC, and IDH.
These patterns are different than what we are seeing in therapy-related myeloid neoplasms.
So when we think about predicting myeloid neoplasms, and I talked yesterday about all
of the scoring criteria, I want to point out that none of them are validated for therapy-related
myeloid neoplasms or in the setting of selective pressures from chemotherapy,
radiation, and other small molecules. So we cannot use these for prediction
risk. We also know from long-term population studies, this is our work from the Women's
Health Initiative, that the median doubling time of mutations in the absence of chemotherapy is
almost seven years. So these are slow-growing mutations. When you see a rapid rise in clone
size in the setting of selective pressure, this is clearly different and more predictive of our
therapy-related diseases. So if you think about then what causes therapy-related myeloid neoplasms,
there's two scenarios. That age-related CH is present at baseline, and because of selective
pressures, there's expansion of these clones, ultimately leading to therapy-related myeloid
neoplasms in certain individuals. Or there is a direct toxicity and DNA damage leading to
new myeloid neoplasms. So there's a direct toxicity and DNA damage leading to new myeloid neoplasms.
So there's a direct toxicity and DNA damage leading to new myeloid neoplasms. So there's a direct toxicity and DNA damage leading to new myeloid neoplasms.
Thank you.